what is racism
how much of it is in our world today
if we were thinking about this activity
of hitler's plotting
how um
and trying to steal man the case of if
not critical race theory but people who
who look for racism in our world
how much would you say
well let's it's a good thing to try to
define i would say that
racism is the the belief that other
people are inferior to you you could say
you could see a form where you thought
people were superior to you that could
also happen but more commonly
you see a group of people as being
inferior to you simply by dint with the
fact that they have a different
racial background
and um
that's sort of the easiest way to define
racism
uh
as i say i mean there are types of
racism i mean mainly anti-semitism
actually perhaps it's the only one
which weirdly
relies on on a hatred of people who
a certain type of person thinks things
are better than them
and that's a particular peculiarity one
of the peculiarities of anti-semitism
well anti-semitism somehow does both
right yes well one of the eternal
fascinating things about anti-semitism
it can do it does everything at the same
time
it's like uh quantum racism yeah they're
both superior and inferior you know that
you do you know um
vastly grossman's life and fate
so in the middle of life and fate um
which a persian friend of mine said was
one of only two great novels of the 20th
century she was very harsh literally
critic
what was the other one oh the leopard
obviously
the leopard the leopard of giuseppe de
la producer yeah okay is she definitely
right on that one
life and fate is is learning so much
today yes the life of fate is a um
is uh an extraordinary book
mainly about
well you know grossman was a um
uh
obviously jewish himself but he uh
he he saw
uh almost everything that he could have
done in the second voice he saw
stalingrad
who was a journalist and he
he he wrote firsthand the account of
starting groudon he he was also the
first journalist interview into blinker
and his account which you can read in
one of the collections of his journalism
his account of walking into treblinka is
just one of the most devastating
haunting pieces of journalism or prose
you can read anyhow i mentioned him
because grossman at the at the in the
middle of life and fate which is about
sort of a 900 page novel
um
in the middle of it which is about the
dark axis around stalingrad
uh
he way at one point he amazingly sort of
goes into the minds of earth hitler and
stalin and
he says he says stalin in his study
feels
his counterpart in berlin and he says he
feels very close to him at this moment
wow
around stalingrad like leading up to
after stalingrad when the germans had
lost he says he feels closeness of
hitler
but grossman in the middle of life and
fate slap bang at the worst hours of the
20th century
suddenly dedicates a chapter to
anti-semitism
and i've seen anti-semitism something
i've always been very interested in uh
because i've always had
the instinctive utter revulsion of it
and um
also partly because of having seen bits
of it
in the middle east and elsewhere but
uh i mentioned this because grossman in
the middle of life and face has it takes
time out and does this like three-page
explanation
three-page description of anti-semitism
and it's extraordinary i mean it's it's
the only thing i can think of that's
equally good is
um
uh
um
gregor of unread story uh
who
wrote a luridly titled but um brilliant
set of novels called the confessions of
an anti-semite
and
about pre-war pre-first world war
anti-semitism in eastern and central
europe anyway
grossman says
in the middle of life and fate the the
the the one of the extraordinary things
about anti-semitism is that he does
everything at the same time the jews get
condemned in one place for being rich
and in another for being poor condemned
in one place for assimilating in another
for not assimilating
uh
for assimilating too much and
assimilating too little
for being too successful for not being
successful enough so it's i think it's
the only racism that includes within it
a detestation for the real anti-semite
a detestation of people that the person
may perceive to be better than them
correctly or otherwise by the way um i'm
embarrassed to say i have not read this
one of two greatest novels of the 20th
essentially life in faith
and just to read off of wikipedia if you
see a gross many ukrainian jew became a
correspondent for the soviet military
paper krasnod
having volunteered and been rejected for
military service he spent a thousand
days in the front lines roughly three of
the four years of the conflict between
the germans and soviets and the main
themes covered in
uh
how's it go life and fate i keep
sticking
is a theme on jewish identity in the
holocaust grossman's idea of humanity
and the human goodness stalin's
distortion of reality and values
and uh science like goes on in reality
of war it's interesting i need to
definitely you need to read it you'll i
think you'll really get a lot from it
one of the other things certainly one
reference but one of the other things he
does is that he he has this
extraordinary ability to to talk about
the the other the absolute highest
levels of the conflict and then zoom in
it's rather like the camera work they
use in things like lord of the rings
where he zooms down then gets one person
in the midst of all this and you get you
you get on there what puts you in the
study too so i i personally
have read and re-read the uh william
shatters the rise and fall of the third
reich who's another journalist
who was there
but he does not do it interestingly
enough given such a large
novel kind of the definitive work on his
the definitive original work that goes
to source materials and on hitler he
doesn't
uh touch
anti-semitism really
big thing to miss out well he just says
it
very calmly and objectively as he does
for most the work that this was
the fact
of
life there's a lot of cruelty throughout
but he doesn't get to well
one of the things is because they lost
the war because of anti-semitism
you know i mean that's one quite
important way to to view this andrew
roberts another historian said is that
you know in the end the nazis lost the
war because they were nazis
it sounds almost too neat but it's it's
worth remembering that you know
at the end of the war when the germans
need to be transporting troops and they
need to be transporting very basic
supplies
eichmann makes sure he gets the trains
to transport the jews
right up to the end
well that's that's certainly uh that's a
dark possibility you know anyhow but to
go back to racism in general racism in
general apart from anti-semitism relies
on
the the um
perception that another group of people
a racial group
other than your own are inferior to you
that that's what i'd say is the easiest
shorthand of racism and of course
it's
one of the stupidest things that our
species is capable of
i mean one of the stupidest that you can
look at a person and guess them
in their entirety in fact
because of their skin color i mean it's
like
what a stupid idea that is
as well as being an evil one but the the
the i would say that one of the
i think it's a dangerous thing in our
era that there are bits of it coming
back that's why i say we do need sort of
we need our antennae working
we just don't need them to be over
active or under active
you